[Música]
ó uma das primeiras lembranças que eu
tenho da minha infância é do jogo de
futebol entre brasil e itália na copa do
mundo de 1982 em casa lotada a família
reunida
muita confusão barulho com certeza
comida lembra absolutamente nada do jogo
em si mas sim das emoções daquele dia
que começaram com euforia alegria e
depois de 90 minutos se transformará em
tristeza e decepção
apesar da derrota e da eliminação aquela
seleção ficaria conhecida como uma das
melhores da nossa história
o exemplo daqueles atletas e de muitos
outros que eu tive a oportunidade de
acompanhar na vida sempre foi fonte de
inspiração muito grande pra mim talvez
por isso eu tenho escolhido começar a
minha carreira trabalhando com esporte
trabalhei na reabilitação de atletas de
alto rendimento de atletas de fim de
semana e também de muitos não atletas
cuja força de superação para mim sempre
foi digna de medalha
depois disso por uma série de
circunstâncias que eu nunca teria sido
capaz de prever mas eu acho que eu fui
curioso o suficiente para perseguir e
acabei tratando de um outro tipo de
paciente
os governos formalmente
eu virei um consultor em gestão mas
talvez condicionado pela minha própria
trajetória eu sempre enxerguei como
profissional de saúde
o fato é que muitos dos nossos governos
hoje em dia estão claramente doentes
uma pesquisa global recente as pessoas
foram perguntados em que medida elas
acreditam que o seu governo nacional é
capaz de fazer o que é certo para o país
na maioria absoluta dos casos a
proporção de pessoas que têm alta ou
mesmo alguma confiança de que o governo
é capaz de fazer o que é certo é menor
do que 50% no brasil então a situação é
crítica apenas 2% da população têm alta
confiança no governo
76% são absolutamente céticos mas mais
importante que a frustração direcionado
aos políticos em si é um crescente senso
de decepção com o sistema político de
maneira mais ampla
no brasil a cada três pessoas duas
acreditam que a democracia não tem
funcionado bem para o país
a minha transformação pessoal e
profissional envolveu uma transição
entre dois mundos o mundo das pessoas no
mundo das instituições de atletas para
governos
essa transição
gostaria de provocá los a pensar sobre
ela qual é a conexão entre esses dois
mundos o que existe de comum entre eles
e o que um pode aprender com o outro
eu vou compartilhar com vocês dois
problemas que eu vejo em comum entre
pessoas e instituições
em seguida três lições que acredito que
os governos podem aprender com os
atletas de alto rendimento
desde que comecei a trabalhar com
governos sempre me chama muito atenção a
semelhança entre esses pacientes
institucionais e os pacientes
individuais que atendia no meu
consultório
alguns exemplos disso muito vocês já
ouviram falar do conceito de um espasmo
sexo não tiveram o desprazer de
experimentar isso na pele
o espasmo é uma contração involuntária
dos músculos
geralmente é bastante doloroso nessa
situação os músicos entre uma situação
de praticidade que impede o desempenho
das funções mais básicas
imagine uma pessoa que quer segurar um
copo mas devido a essa contração
constante dos músicos das mãos
ela não consegue desempenhar a função de
maneira semelhante
muitos de nossos governos hoje em dia
vivem em estado de espasmo diante das
crescentes pressões para os resultados
eles tentam fazer demais e abraçar muito
ao mesmo tempo só que acabou cansando de
- e terminando exaustos
eles entram em um estado que a gente
pode chamar de paralisia hiperativa
sempre estão muito ocupados mas isso não
significa que eles atingir os melhores
resultados
o roteiro dessa história é muito bem
familiar para muitos de nós
ela começa com promessas inspiradoras de
campanha eleitoral passa os
planejamentos estratégicos igualmente
maravilhosos e termina muitas vezes com
a frustração diante das dificuldades de
implementação
além do espaço uma outra forma
comparativa de entender as comparações
entre atletas e governos
é o que acontece em uma articulação
depois de um trauma eu vivi isso na pele
quando rompeu o ligamento do joelho
praticando esporte por sinal
o fato é que depois de um trauma o
inchaço na articulação eo dano nas
terminações nervosas que uma situação
que a gente chama de perda de próprios
excepção própria opção é a capacidade
inata que nós temos de entender onde o
nosso corpo está no espaço entender como
reagir os diferentes obstáculos que a
gente tem no dia a dia
diante de um trauma a gente perde isso o
sintoma
normalmente é uma insegurança para se
movimentar por que a gente não entende
bem onde está pisando e nem como reagir
a essas pedras no caminho
o equivalente à perda de provas e psam
no contexto de governo
a gente poderia chamar de falta de
memória institucional assim como o nosso
corpo não faltam neurônios
os governos são inundados por dados
informações das mais diferentes fontes e
espécies
o governo já tinha a oportunidade de
trabalhar em apenas um ministério
existiam 350 sistemas de informação
o interessante é que a existência desses
dados não significam nada que o governo
tomar as melhores decisões para
transformar a vida das pessoas
o que importa na verdade são as conexões
a capacidade de traduzir esses dados e
inteligência ea inteligência em decisões
que melhorem a vida das pessoas imagina
o governo que por exemplo tenta melhorar
a situação de segurança pública mas que
não sabe onde o crime é mais prevalente
qual tipo de crime afeta mais a
população o qual tem sido resultado da
sua última política de prevenção nas
comunidades assim como as pessoas
este governo tende a ficar inseguro e
não saber onde está pisando as decisões
nesse caso ao invés de se basear nos
dados nas evidências são dominadas por
decisões e pressões políticas isso tende
a não dar certo
a lista de exemplos comparativos dos
problemas poderia ser longa mas chega um
momento que é importante virar essa
chave e começar a falar sobre solução
a pergunta realmente importante é o que
a gente pode fazer a respeito disso
como criar governos que funcionam de
fato das pessoas e aqui eu acho que o
exemplo do sport mais uma vez pode nos
ajudar
quando eu comecei sempre desde que eu me
apaixonei pelo esporte sempre sempre
achei curioso uma pergunta que sim
ele me acompanhou foi o que separa esses
super atletas de elite de todos nós
meros mortais
muita gente acredita que se a função de
talento do dom pra mim essa resposta
nunca foi suficiente
minha curiosidade é que essas pessoas
fazem no dia a dia quais são os
comportamentos os hábitos as práticas
que justificam os resultados
espetaculares que elas atingem mais
recentemente eu acho que a mesma
pergunta tem me acompanhado só que num
contexto de governos
o que diferencia um governo que é capaz
de entregar resultados para as pessoas
independente do seu ponto de partida
daqueles outros que se mantém sempre
estagnados ou até mesmo ficando cada vez
pior
gostaria de compartilhar três lições que
eu acho que os governos têm a aprender
com esses atletas de elite
a primeira delas tem a ver com foco no
esporte a definição de sucesso e muitas
vezes clara acertar o alvo correr mais
longe pular mais alto fazer mais pontos
que o adversário só que uma
característica marcante desses atletas
de alto desempenho é que eles têm a sua
própria definição de sucesso clara
específica e ambiciosa
eles querem ganhar uma medalha olímpica
eles querem bater o seu próprio recorde
pessoal no contexto de governo
o foco é igualmente importante mas muito
mais difícil pela própria natureza do
setor público que envolve uma negociação
de vários interesses quando os governos
conseguem estabelecer foco muitas vezes
não conseguem comunicar isso de maneira
suficiente
um exemplo ótimo aconteceu recentemente
em um dos governos da américa latina não
tive a oportunidade de trabalhar em que
quando eu olhei para o programa de
governo e isso era repetido
constantemente nos discursos políticos
o principal objetivo colocado ali era de
proporcionar a todos cidadãos uma boa
vida e proporcionar a todos cidadãos uma
boa vida
o objetivo sem dúvida nobre que merece
ser perseguido
mas ele acrescenta pouco do ponto de
vista de gestão
afinal de contas como que esse governo
vai saber se ele está indo por um bom
caminho o pro mau caminho
como ele sabe se ele entregou o que ele
se propôs a fazer desde o início
compare isso com outro governo da
américa latina onde a liderança máxima
do sistema veio a público dizer que
gostaria com a qualidade daquela
administração fosse julgada pelo
desempenho do país em sete áreas
prioritárias não
mil 7 e para cada uma dessas áreas
pelo menos uma meta veja uma dessas
metas reduzir de 44 a 19 por cento
a prevalência de anemia entre crianças
de 6 a 35 meses até o final do ano de
2021 uma meta específica clara que
orienta os resultados e favorece toda a
cooperação nos setores de governo cada
um sabe o que pode fazer para atingir
esse norte comum
o foco é um excelente ponto de partida
mas ele sozinho não é suficiente
a segunda disciplina que eu acho que une
governos e atletas de alto desempenho é
o compromisso com as rotinas de
implementação
quando a gente ouve falar na palavra
rotina muitas vezes o que vem à cabeça é
sofrimento tédio marasmo mas o conceito
que estou fazendo aqui é um pouco
diferente
é um conceito de repetição positiva uma
certa previsibilidade um ritmo que
permite com que o sistema prenda e
cresça sempre quando nós observamos a
televisão um atleta de alta performance
é muito difícil é exata dimensão de todo
o trabalho duro que permitiu que aquela
pessoa chegasse até ali um segundo de
genialidade na televisão na verdade é
construído por milhares de falhas mas
além dessas falhas uma tensão uma
obsessão enorme o detalhe eo próprio
compromisso enorme de fazer um pouco
melhor a cada dia
os governos a rotina é igualmente
importante mas ela tem uma forma um
pouco diferente ela também acontece fora
dos holofotes mas os governos isso
funciona como reuniões entre as pessoas
certas no tempo certo para tomar a
decisão certa
as rotinas permitem com que os governos
identifica os problemas antes que eles
virem crise que possam tomar ação
efetiva para corrigir a imagem de um
governo que quer melhorar a situação de
educação do seu país mas que sabe que as
os alunos não aprendem porque falta
eletricidade saneamento água uma
realidade muito comum em várias cidades
da américa latina e do mundo e um
governo movido por rotinas primeiro
lugar as autoridades sabem o que
acontece na realidade elas não ficam
trancadas no seu escritório em segundo
lugar
as pessoas diferentes setores têm a
oportunidade de conversar entre si e
tomar as decisões certas neste caso o
ministro
o diretor de educação poderia conversar
com a pessoa certa de eletricidade e
saneamento para resolver os problemas
que precisam ser resolvidos
um general no século 19
dizia que nenhum plano é capaz de
resistir
o primeiro contato com o inimigo a gente
trouxe esse conceito com a realidade do
esporte
a gente poderia dizer que nenhum plano é
capaz de resistir o primeiro contato com
o adversário o que explica porque muitas
vezes os técnicos vão à loucura porque
suas equipes não conseguem executar o
que foi falado nos vestiários a
realidade da partida muitas vezes é
diferente trazendo esse conceito para a
realidade do governo
a gente poderia dizer que nenhum plano é
capaz de resistir o primeiro contato com
a realidade dos cidadãos
e esse é justamente o poder das rotinas
de implementação
eles permitem que o governo mantenha uma
noção em tempo real do que está
acontecendo
ao dedicar 90% da energia para o
planejamento
a premissa por trás disso é de que é
possível identificar os obstáculos ao
longo do caminho
antes mesmo de a gente começar a
implementar uma política pública
eu não quero aqui desmerecer o valor de
um bom planejamento
mas eu acho que realmente diferencia o
governo de alto desempenho é a sua
capacidade de execução é a velocidade
com que ele reage aos obstáculos e
talvez mais importante a sua qualidade
de aprendizado em cada um desses pontos
de reflexão e de controle
por fim é importante reconhecer que toda
essa história de alto desempenho cansa
chegar lá e manter se lá existe um
sacrifício enorme
muitos de nós diante de algum sucesso
tem a tendência de acomodação de marães
rosa dizia que o animal satisfeito door
no pará que buscar mais se o que existe
já parece bastar
o curioso é que os atletas de ponta
parecem nunca está satisfeito
para eles essas pessoas têm uma relação
quase que fanática com o desafio a
excelência é uma questão espiritual
o transcendental é parte do dna dessas
pessoas
quando eu sair de um ambiente como esse
e mergulhei no ambiente de governo
eu esperava um choque tremendo afinal de
contas nossos governos são conhecidos
lentidão complacência um lugar de
trabalho para quem não quer trabalhar em
um lugar para pessoas que muitas vezes
já têm o que queria uma estabilidade e
que portanto podem dormir
infelizmente essa é uma realidade que
ainda existe sim mas a minha grata
surpresa eu tenho tido a oportunidade de
trabalhar com governos que realmente
prezam por uma cultura de alta
performance
esses governos são capazes de manter a
ambição ea persistência
mesmo quando o jogo parece perdido eles
sabem que para vencer para realmente
transformar uma sociedade é preciso mais
do que simples ferramentas e técnicas de
gestão é preciso valorizar a cultura
investir nas pessoas
investir em comunicação produzir
relacionamentos efetivos
esse é o grande valor de governos de
alta performance
além disso eles usam as pequenas
vitórias para construir espaços para
transformações mais profundas e assim
como os atletas
eles nunca se dão por satisfeitos uma
grande conquista no esporte é um feito
importante para muitos de nós trazer
folia alegria senso de comunidade
só que é importante reconhecer que os
nossos governos joga um jogo muito mais
decisivo fazer com que os nossos
governos funcionem para todos os
cidadãos é provavelmente o maior desafio
moral dos nossos tempos
em uma época de polarização ideológica
sem precedentes
eu acho que é fundamental que a gente
resgate para frente desse debate que
significa um bom governo que fala que
fornece as condições e os direitos
básicos dos cidadãos
isso não deveria depender de afiliação
partidária ou ideológica
ayrton sena os maiores ídolos do esporte
no brasil tem uma frase que eu considero
genial ele dizia o seguinte
o importante é ganhar tudo e sempre essa
história de que o importante é competir
e não passa de pura demagogia pra mim
essa frase sempre foi um lembrete
poderoso do valor da gente colocar a
ênfase nos resultados
esforçar-se sim é importante mas não é
suficiente
nós precisamos criar governo os
vencedores para que o aluno quando
termina essa universidade vença para que
o jovem que não teve acesso à
universidade vença para o trabalhador
que acorda todos os dias às 5 horas da
manhã vença para que a nossa sociedade
vença muito obrigado
[Aplausos]